the cause of a fire at one of the
world's tallest residential buildings is
under investigation this morning
dramatic video shows the flames
engulfing part of the middle eastern
skyscraper overnight the fire sent
chunks of debris crashing to the ground
incredibly everyone made it out alive
this is the second time in recent years
the Dubai building known as torch tower
has caught fire
Jonathan Vigliotti is in London and has
the latest on the investigation
Jonathan good morning good morning the
iconic tower earned its name because it
was one of the first mega rises in Dubai
but last night it literally looked like
a torch after the fire engulfed 40
floors the massive flames lit up the
night as they spread up one side of the
tower tearing through more than 40
floors burning embers and chunks of
debris showered the streets below Mahal
as firefighters battled the high-rise
Inferno the 86 story torch Tower is one
of the world's tallest residential
buildings with more than 600 homes the
fire started around 1:00 a.m. when many
people inside were asleep
[Music]
incredibly Dubai fire officials say no
one was hurt
and the flames were under control in
just two hours it's the second massive
fire at the tower in just over two years
in February 2015
flames swallowed the building again no
one was injured
fire officials say the fire was likely
accelerated by the exterior cladding or
siding which was replaced last year
similar cladding is blamed for fueling
London's grenfell Tower fire in June at
least 80 people were killed as flames
engulfed the building in minutes and
it's still unclear what caused this
morning's fire and whether that cladding
may have played a role residents said
they escaped safely because of working
fire alarms and thanks to building staff
who went door to door to ensure everyone
evacuated and Lennon's Grenfell fire if
you recall people were initially told to
stay inside Jeff